Jacob and I are going to California this weekend
for a friend's wedding, and I'm so excited.
I love California. Personally,
this is my third time this year going,
and it's wild, because before this,
I literally never been to California in my life,
and now in one year, I've been three times.
That's just so wild and so fun.
So I'm gonna get my nails done.
I'm gonna change the color.
They just need a little refresh.
I think I'm gonna stick with the fall colors, though,
because I think I'm just feeling it,
you know? I'm thinking, like,
chocolate, maybe,
or a really pretty autumn pumpkin spice feel.
I think that's what we're gonna go with.
She did an amazing job. I love them.
They look like pumpkin spice. They're so stinking cute.